and the military general who took power
from myanmar's democratically elected
government in a coup
six months ago has extended his junta's
state of emergency for
two more years general min aung lang
also announced he would take the title
of prime minister
hundreds have been killed in protests
against the military government
since the coup min insisted myanmar will
hold elections in
2023. we have nothing to lose
but our shackles these two activists are
wearing slokans of defiance
a risky move in a country where speaking
out
can get you killed
we're afraid but behind that fears of
boiling anger that's fueling our
revolution
we won't give up sometimes you have to
take a step back to take two forward
we're fighting back because we're being
oppressed
big protests have become too risky in
their place
flash mobs often lasting only a few
minutes have been breaking out in yangon
and other cities they yelled down with
the dictatorship and we must overcome
a brief battle cry before they disappear
into the back streets
six months after the coup myanmar has
become a full-fledged military state
its leader and self-declared prime
minister minoo lang has extended the
state of emergency
and pushed back long-promised elections
until august 2023
we must create conditions to hold a free
and fair multi-party general election
we have to make preparations i pledge to
hold the multi-party general election
without fail likely to be missing from
the list of candidates
aung san tsuchi the deposed leader is
facing a slew of charges
and what many observers are calling a
sham trial
adding to the political and economic
turmoil the country is seeing a sharp
spike in covet cases
pushing the health care system closer to
the brink of collapse
as people wait in line to get oxygen
with many medics part of the civil
disobedience movement
they become a target of violent abuse by
the military
human rights organizations are calling
on the international community
to act the un can also step up
the security council should be doing
everything they can
to ensure that an arms embargo is
enforced and that the myanmar military
can no longer buy weapons from anyone
around the world
even so these activists say they'll
never be able to trust the military
that's a sentiment echoed by many around
the country
there come a moment when people start to
ask themselves do i want to sit at home
and wait for them to kill me
or do i want to die fighting i think
they'll get up and fight
six months after the coup myanmar
increasingly looks like a tinderbox
waiting to explode and let's go to
mangzarni human rights activist and
co-founder of forces of renewal for
southeast
asia who joins us now from london a very
warm welcome
to the show so two years until the next
elections we just heard that announced
by the military general looking ahead to
2023
can we trust this timeline
absolutely not it's not just the one
general that we cannot trust
it is the entire armed forces that the
public does
uh do not trust because you know this is
the repeat
or the vicious uh pattern of the
military
uh they're coming in claiming to hold
the free and fair elections or creating
conditions for free and fair elections
uh since 1958 that's over
60 years so almost three generations of
burmese generals
have played this game um as long as they
do not get the results they
want which is installing a government
appliable employing to the military's
dictates
they will keep canceling any election
there's
absolutely no credence the public
consider
this institution wants a national
liberation force
today a terrorist you know organization
uh in charge of parts of the state
because we don't have a
functioning state in burma anymore okay
so does that then spell the end of an
attempt at democracy in myanmar
yes we are in fact um you know
plunging into um you know rather
unprecedented situation
we have been in civil war uh you know
for the last 70 plus
years but the this time what is
unprecedented about the situation
uh there's the the entire majoritarian
burmese buddhist
public turning against the institutions
once they took pride in and and whose
actions they defended even
you know in the case of uh the
institutions
uh genocide against a muslim rohingya so
so
we are looking into a very very dark
space and now you know here let me just
say one thing
which is that very very worrying the may
online the military coup leader
he is likely to be issued icc
warrant before 2023
for his leadership in the crimes against
humanity against a one million
rohingya uh you know icc has a full
investigation going on going at the
moment against
burma and he is using
religion in his speech you know what
it's the equivalent of uh race baiting
you know he's using is telling the
public
that the last five years under aung san
tsuji government
the buddhists have been you know unhappy
or marginalized
in a country an overwhelming majority
are buddhists and so this is that sense
of marginalization
we are seeing across the country i'm
afraid we're going to have to leave it
there but thank you so much
for coming on to the show monsanto human
rights activist and co-founder of forces
of renewal for southeast asia